we're here today at the Santa Monica
Boys & Girls Club for the launch of
ports horizon 2 we had an opportunity to
be able to surprise them with the fleet
of awesome Lamborghinis it's an exciting
moment and I saw the eyes light up
especially when they heard the roar of
the engine and as nothing like seeing
the car roll into an area and they look
beautiful still but even better when
they're moving I'm the excitement to
speak the buzz was intense it felt like
the Superbowl was filming our Boys and
Girls Clubs just seeing the kids walk up
and seeing the cars outside and the slew
of questions that in super just it's
unforgiving when you come into the Boys
and Girls Club we really try to work on
an experience opportunities and
expectations given the kids a sense of
belonging a sense of usefulness the
Ford's a team came in and they gave us
the opportunity to let the kids design a
car to actually be in the game hundreds
of kids submitted awesome designs for
the contest and we're actually going to
be recreating those in-game and gifting
those after the community so their
drawings have become a reality in the
game I wish that I was their age why I
had the chance to drawn compete as well
the kids really put their heart and soul
into it and to be able to see them put
the things on that I would never think
of you know like a diamond or a bow
that's their vision of our brand and
they're making it their own it's so
inspired it's so kind of innocent
beautiful and yet at the same time it's
not what you'd expect to be on a car the
winners are gonna feel comforted like
hey you know what I took a design I used
my skills and now I'm inside of a
videogame I learned something the mantra
the kind of what's been going on today
with all of the amazing volunteers and
all the people that have brought this
experience today is kind of done I quali
your dreams you know and the gentleman
from Lamborghini would never tell
the kids a history lesson on how
Lamborghini started out making tractors
that gentlemen made that tractor fall
his dreams he never probably imagined
that there would be Lamborghinis and a
Boys and Girls Club it started off as a
presentation and then it became a Q&A it
was clear that they're really engaged
and they're really interested in not
only what Lamborghini is doing as a
brand but also what we're doing here I
think the kids me and I are really kind
of brings that brings that message home
if you follow your dreams anything is
possible